So
Stephanie,
you ask a great question,
how likely is it that we're going to
find life on a planet outside the Earth
in your lifetime,
say in the next 40 or 50 years?
And of course this is something that
nobody can answer.
Exactly.
We don't know.
That's,
that's the answer,
but I think it's very likely indeed.
Now when I say life,
there's a lot of ways you can take that
word.
You know,
I'm not really talking about
civilizations or spaceships or things
like that.
I think it's much more likely that we're
going to find microbes,
simple life.
But to me that would be really,
really exciting.
There are several places in our own
solar system right now that we think
might be good environments for life,
and as I said before,
we haven't found proof of life yet,
but we've found some very,
very interesting things.
For example,
on Mars,
Mars has an atmosphere.
It's much thinner than the earth's,
but it's still there.
We think there might even be water
underneath the surface of Mars.
And recently we've detected organic
molecules which are sort of the building
blocks of our chemistry on Mars as well.
It's possible that the surface of Mars
itself is not a very good place for
life,
but maybe underneath meters under the
soil in the rock you could find bacteria
and there are a lot of analogs to this
on earth.
Similar things on earth,
we find bacteria that can exist as a
mild under the earth.
We find these things in gold mines very,
very deep under the earth.
You break open the rocks and there's
actually bacteria living in the rocks
very far down into the earth and there
are other places in the outer solar
system that we think are great
environments for life too.
There are moons of Jupiter and Saturn
that we know have liquid water oceans.
For example,
Europa is a moon of Jupiter and we know
that your rope,
it has vast reservoirs of liquid water
that are protected by a shell of ice.
In fact,
this one moon of Jupiter,
Europa actually has far more liquid
water on it than earth does.
And there are some suggestions that
there might be interesting chemistry as
well.
There's also a moon of Saturn called
enceladus and the same thing applies.
There's a liquid water ocean under ice
and in the case of enceladus you
actually have cracks in the ice that the
water is flying out of and turning into
ice crystals.
We actually flew our Cassini spacecraft
through these jets coming out of
enceladus and we detected organic
molecules.
So we know that there is warm salt
water,
there's interesting chemistry.
It's a great place to go looking for
life.
And there's another moon of Saturn to
called Titan,
which is very different from that and
has an atmosphere.
We actually think that there are lakes
of methane,
not water,
but actually liquid methane on the
surface.
And below that there's probably liquid
water underneath.
So you have liquid water,
you have organics,
you have an atmosphere.
Maybe that'd be a great place to go
looking for some microbes.
So some people say that's not very
exciting.
You know,
we're not going to find aliens in the
sense of spaceships and you know,
cling ons and any science fiction you
want.
I,
for one though,
I'm going to be very excited when we
find any evidence of life outside the
earth.
I actually have a bottle of champagne
chilling because I think it could happen
almost any day when some of our rovers
or some of our satellites around other
planets come back with really
interesting data.
Think about the questions we can answer.
Does life,
even if it's at a bacteria level of,
even if it's just a tiny little bit of
life,
does it have DNA?
Is it similar to us?
Is it different from us?
We finally have the next example of how
life can form and how life can evolve
and our view of the universe will never
be the same again.
And my bet is that's going to happen in
the next 50 years.